fueron Encontraron la semana pasada
concretamente el 16 de enero y fue CNN
el medio que primero reveló esta noticia
que es el encargado o el representante
abogado de el ex vicepresidente Mike
pence fue el encargado de comunicar esta
información a través de un documento
escrito que entregó a las autoridades
correspondientes Jacob dijo que el
vicepresidente pues está dispuesto a
seguir colaborando con todo el resto de
allanamientos que pueden derivar después
de este allanamiento que se hizo y
después de haber encontrado estos
documentos en la casa personal de en el
estado de Indiana fueron en total dos
cajas con documentos con confidenciales
y pues esto pues ponen aprietos y
posiblemente abrirá una investigación el
gobierno para el manejo de estos
documentos por parte del ex
vicepresidente
Cristóbal podría afectar esto la
eventual candidatura de pence a la
presidencia en el en representación del
partido republicano
claro es que los nombres que ya se
conocen son de precandidatos
republicanos son Donald santis actual
gobernador de la Florida y Mike pence
quien ha estado pues muy abierto a
compartir ese interés que tiene llegar a
la casa blanca sin embargo las preguntas
más que si se ve afectado de Cara a este
nuevo descubrimiento de documentos
confidenciales La pregunta es cómo están
manejando los líderes del país los
excedentes y los expresidentes esta
información confidencial que pues pone a
aprietos la seguridad nacional como lo
ha dicho el propio FBI